[APPLAUSE]
TIM SNEATH: Thank you, guys.
Welcome to DartConf.
It's so good to
have you all here.
My name is Tim Sneath
and I'm the Group Product
Manager for Flutter and Dart.
I've been only at Google
for about nine weeks so far,
after joining from
Microsoft where I spent just
under 20 years working on
different client technologies,
including WPF, Silverlight,
Internet Explorer, and Windows.
Honestly, I expected to be with
Microsoft for a good many years
to come.
But about six months ago,
I came across Flutter.
And I kind of fell in love.
So today I want to
tell you a little bit
about what brought me here.
So we're going to be
talking about out two
primary technologies
this morning.
Of course, one is Dart.
This is, after all,
the Dart Conference.
And Dart is a fast, powerful,
and productive language
that is optimized for
client-side development.
The other is Flutter,
which is a new mobile UI
framework from
Google for crafting
high-quality, native
experiences for iOS and Android.
Over the last couple
of weeks, we've
been iterating on our
vision to try and make sure
that we fully convey the
opportunity that we see here.
And here's what
we've come up with.
We want to help developers craft
beautiful, native experiences
across all screens with a
client-optimized language,
rich, powerful frameworks,
and delightful and flexible
tooling.
And we believe we're at a
unique inflection point,
at this time, in building mobile
application software, where
the time is ripe for new
framework that combines
all these attributes together.
So I want to tell
you a story about one
of the first companies to
build an application using
this framework and
their experiences.
In fact, instead of me
telling you the story,
I want to show you
this short video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- "Hamilton" is one of the most
talked-about and best-loved
musicals, with shows
on Broadway, in London,
and around the country.
We wanted something
to make the show more
accessible for our fans.
So we wanted to develop an
app to meet the needs of fans
as we started to
expand the brand.
We turned to Posse, a New
York based development firm,
to help us develop
the Hamilton app.
Hamilton's Flutter app launched
in the App Store and the Play
Store three months after we
wrote our first line of code.
And we accomplished a ton.
Fans can enter a daily lottery
for a shot at $10 tickets,
buy merchandise through
an e-commerce experience,
take selfie photos
with the HamCam,
and get daily news and updates.
- We knew that this app needed
to be rock solid, both in terms
of performance and
visual fidelity,
and really represent the amazing
experience that the "Hamilton"
show itself provides.
And ultimately, that's why
we decided to use Flutter.
- Flutter is a mobile UI
toolkit that allows developers
and designers to
craft beautiful,
native experiences on iOS and
Android and is entirely free
and open-source.
- We have very high expectations
of quality for the apps
that we build.
We expect pixel-perfect results.
And we need them to be
very high-performance.
Flutter gave us a lot of
opportunities that previously
weren't available to us.
The fact that it's
a single codebase
drastically improved
our ability to deliver
a consistent experience
across platforms.
Its hot reload
gives us an ability
to build more
features in less time.
- It allowed me to make
changes really fast and iterate
through the UI without having
to stop and restart the app.
Coming from an iOS and
Android background,
it's something that I've been
waiting for for a long time.
The Flutter developer
community is very active.
Drop-in packages helped
us maximize productivity.
It helped us integrate elements
like Firebase and Cloud.
- At the end of
the day, we're just
really happy that
we found Flutter
so that we can build these
beautiful, native interfaces
for both iOS and Android
from a single codebase.
- We were given a
really tight timeline
and we turned the app
around faster than I ever
could have imagined.
We were able to make changes
right up to the night
before we went live and really
feel confident about them.
In fact, we pushed an
entirely new feature
to the App Store the
day before we launched.
- And since launch, Flutter's
efficiency and speed
has helped us to
build new features,
such as the recent trivia game.
We're really excited because
as the show continues to grow,
we're going to be able to keep
pace with a ton of new features
that's going to make
the app even better.
- We couldn't be more
thrilled with Flutter.
It has enabled us to use one
codebase to deliver a truly
high-quality app that
"Hamilton" fans have absolutely
fallen in love with.
- We're thrilled with what
Posse was able to deliver.
The entire brand
of "Hamilton" is
about delivering on an
experience for fans.
They're thrilled
about the new features
that we're rolling out.
And we're really excited to
see where the app goes next.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
TIM SNEATH: So cool!
I got to hang out with
some of the team from Posse
last week in New York.
And it's amazing what
they've done there.
I particularly love
the speed that they
were able to start building
and get a great result
on their Hamilton app.
And the results are in
from the various stores.
We've already seen a
million or more installs
of the Hamilton app with over
450,000 monthly, active users.
So it's been a really powerful
experience and a great example
of how Dart and Flutter
come together to build
great application experiences.
OK, so let's break
it down a little.
We're going to spend the next
little while talking about each
of these three parts
and why we think,
together, they
make this platform
a compelling opportunity
for client developers.
I'm going to start with
the language, which
is, of course, Dart.
So Dart is the backbone for
everything we're building.
It's a stable, complete,
battle-tested language.
This isn't an
architectural diagram,
but Dart is more than just
a language, of course.
It includes a set
of core libraries.
It includes compilers,
transpilers.
It's got runtime support for
advanced language capabilities
like garbage collection,
as well as a rich ecosystem
of tools and packages.
And Dart started on the web
but we've evolved it over time
to add mobile.
And that's been our
direction moving forward.
As we look across the
web, we're seeing evidence
that Dart is starting
to become popular.
We used Google BigQuery to do
a scan across the public GitHub
corpus to see how
many lines of code
there were out there with Dart.
And we're already
seeing that there's
over 70 million lines
of code out there.
And you can see that over
the last couple of years,
Dart is starting to take off.
It's not a top-10
language yet, but as you
can see from the shape
of this TIOBE index,
Dart is really starting to climb
up the rankings or the ratings.
OK, but there are lots
of languages out there.
Why do we specifically
think Dart is a good one?
Well, there are three
things in my mind.
Firstly, as you saw
with the Hamilton app
and as you'll see
again later, Flutter
has this amazing capability
called hot reload which
allows you to deploy an
application to your device
and continue to change
it in profound ways
while it's still running.
And hot reload let's you quickly
iterate on your UI design.
You can make changes
to your application
and continue immediately to see
the results of those changes
whilst the application
keeps running.
And that doesn't just happen.
It's powered by Dart.
Dart provides a JIT compiler.
And it provides the support
and integration with Flutter
at runtime for changing
code and keeping
the state alive as
the new pieces of code
are deployed into the VM.
Secondly, Dart is near
unique in having a number
of different outputs for it.
Dart is designed
around the ability
to support mobile
and web applications.
If you're building a mobile
application as a developer,
we have a JIT compiler
that gives you
the great developer support
for things like hot reload.
But we also have native,
ahead-of-time compilation
to machine code, whether
it's ARM or something else,
so that you can achieve
that native performance
on your released product.
Similarly, if you're building
a web app, we have transpilers.
And we have a couple
of those as well.
We have one that is designed for
development purposes that has
lightning-speed compilation.
And we also have
one that is designed
for highly-scalable,
production-quality code.
Thirdly, the fact that Dart
can reconstruct the environment
quickly relies on
the memory management
of Dart, a garbage
collector that
is designed around the
client, making allocating
new objects fast and making
short-lived objects very
cheap to manage.
And this is again
an example of how
the partnership of Flutter and
Dart pays off well together.
We worked to have the engine
and the garbage collector
talk to each other so that
garbage collection occurs
during idle times.
And finally, Dart puts
all of these pieces
together in a single language.
It's an open standard.
It's published by Ecma.
It's the same body that
standardizes JavaScript.
Everything's open-source.
It's all published on GitHub.
It's open to inspection and
open to your contributions.
So we mentioned those 70
million lines of code on GitHub.
But how is Google using Dart?
Well, I'd like to invite Kevin
Moore, who is a fellow product
manager on the Dart
team, to come up and talk
a little bit about that.
Kevin.
[APPLAUSE]
KEVIN MOORE: Thanks, Tim.
So a lot of people have
come to Dart recently
because of Flutter.
I'd like to say that
this is not a comeback.
We've been here for years,
actually, over five years
we've been using Dart at Google
primarily on the web side.
And as Tim talked about,
a lot of the features
that make Dart so
powerful are the fact
that we can do language
work and library
work that works great and
builds high-performance,
mission-critical
applications on the web
and on mobile with
no compromises.
A lot of solutions that exist
today that say they can let you
do both.
You really have to do
some tweaking and fighting
to get it working everywhere.
And Dart really nails it.
As Tim mentioned,
we're designed to be
cross-compiled to compile the
really efficient JavaScript.
And we have Dart,
with its type system,
with its strong language
features, allows us to build
giant frameworks, frameworks
that allow us to build things
like AdWords.
So a lot of people aren't
familiar with what AdWords is.
Has anyone here
actually used AdWords?
Oh, there are a few people.
That's good.
Usually in the
engineering crowd,
there aren't a lot of folks.
You've certainly seen
the output of AdWords.
If you ever do a
Google Search, and I'm
guessing a few people
in the room have,
if you see an ad
on Google Search
or even a text ad in
YouTube or Google Shopping,
it was probably
bought via AdWords.
AdWords was completely rewritten
in the last few years with Dart
and our framework AngularDart,
again, all open-source.
And it's really
tough to emphasize
how big a deal this is.
I talked to one of our vice
presidents before the talk.
I was like, can I talk
about how many lines of code
we have in Dart and Google?
And he's like, well, we
really can't talk about that.
And I was like, can we talk
about how many engineers
we have working with our
web tools inside Google?
And he's like, ah,
we really can't
talk about that,
which really taught me
an important thing, which is
always ask for forgiveness
instead of permission.
But what I did ask is like,
well, can I show a demo
and talk about how
much money it makes?
And he's like, well,
that's all public.
I was like, oh, perfect.
So all you have to do is go
look at a quarterly statement
from Google to see how much
money we make on ad revenue.
It's not a small part
of the Google business.
It's all primarily
driven by AdWords.
So I was trying to
think of the superlative
to describe the requirements.
And I think "intimidating"
was the word I landed on
that I liked the most.
This team has to build an app
that has to be rock solid.
Anyone here that has
an application that
takes credit cards, you
realize any minute of downtime
is lost revenue.
So it has to be stable.
It has to be fast.
People expect this
kind of experience,
this rich experience, to feel
like a native application,
like a desktop application.
Remember having
to install those?
And it has to iterate quickly.
This is still a very
competitive business.
The people that buy
ads expect new features
to be rolled out continually.
And so the engineers have to
be able to move really quickly.
And what was great is, because
of Dart's flexibility, its type
system, its core
libraries, it not only
enabled us to build
the frameworks
that we use to
drive these tools,
but allowed us to build
a compelling application.
So without showing you how
to buy an ad on AdWords,
I at least want to show you
the application we have.
If we can switch to
the demo, please.
This is AdWords.
Exciting.
The first thing I want to
do, and it's kind of silly,
I'm going to do the
Shift-Command-R trick just
to show how fast loading
the application is.
This is a giant application.
I don't know if people
have reloaded Gmail before,
but for the size and scale
of what this accomplishes
because we have a very smart
compiler that knows how
to tree shake and do lots
of other clever things,
we actually generate
relatively small binaries
for large applications.
Secondly, I just want to show
some of the richness of this.
Even things like a button click.
I could just do this for hours.
Like the subtle
material animations,
you notice the load animations.
This application
is actually broken
into several small parts.
And we delay load them
as you click around.
This allows our initial
load time to be very small.
It allows us to segment the
application up logically.
And again, this is one
of the things where
having a strong type
system and being
able to rely on things
like static analysis
are really important.
It allows our engineers
to build multiple segments
of a huge application
and have high confidence
that when you deploy, it
all glues together well
and the messages send well.
So things like slide-out
animations, really big lists--
wait for the delay load here--
all work really fast.
And this is 100%
written in Dart.
So if I want to target my
AngularDart ad at my father,
I can go in here very easily
and make sure he sees it.
And even silly things
like the calendar control.
If you look at just the
mouse-over behaviors,
we show the highlight, the
ability to drag and drop.
Tim and I both
spent a lot of time
working on desktop
frameworks where
we had complete control of the
operating system and the OS
stack.
And accomplishing
these kinds of effects
and this kind of speed
was really difficult.
And it's so exciting to
work on a platform that
enables delivering these type
of applications to the open web.
And that's what Dart let us do.
Back to slides please.
So speaking of superlatives,
we talked to Manish
about just the experience of
deploying AdWords with Dart
and, again, how critical it
was to Google's revenue, how
the shape of the language, the
libraries, the tooling we have,
really offered an amazingly
productive experience
for the engineers.
And given what they
came from, it's
a very validating
thing to be a product
manager on because they've
just been so delighted
in their productivity.
And, of course, when you have
very productive engineers
in such a critical
business, that really
maps to increased revenue.
TIM SNEATH: Thank you, Kevin.
[APPLAUSE]
AdWords is such a
great example of how
Dart, coupled with the web
framework that Dart provides,
enables you to build
these highly-scalable,
fast-performance experiences.
So Dart 1 was good.
But we listened to you, people
in our community, people
on GitHub and other
places and you
told us a couple
of things about how
you were using Dart
and some innovations
you'd like to see
in the language.
In particular, you told us that
optional types are sometimes
hard to use.
You told us that as you write
more and more code in Dart,
you'd like us to help
you, as a language,
reduce the amount of
boilerplate code in your code.
And then thirdly, you said you'd
like us to just iterate faster
with the language, to build
new innovations or new language
features into the language.
So today I'm delighted
to formally announce
Dart 2, which is--
[APPLAUSE]
Dart 2 is a reboot of Dart
as a language optimized
for client development.
Dart 2 is mainly
about three things--
Firstly, strong mode; secondly,
some new language features;
and thirdly, a common front-end.
Let's talk about each
of these in turn.
Firstly, strong mode.
So when the team
first designed Dart,
they were inspired by the
dynamic, loose, typing model
of the web.
It seemed great.
But as we scaled up Dart 1 to
extremely large applications,
we found that
stronger typing really
helped us to detect errors.
And, of course, this is
becoming a trend on the web,
as well, as you can see
from the rise of languages
like TypeScript.
So here's an example of how
insidious errors can sometimes
creep into your code with
a weaker type system.
This is a simplified
example of an actual bug
we found in our AdWords code.
You can see here that
there's some code.
It's taking some prices,
trying to sort them, and return
the lowest price.
Any guesses as to what the
price reported will be?
I'm hearing a few
different answers here.
Some expert Dart engineers
have already figured this out.
Maybe they're the
people on the Dart team.
Yeah, the answer is 10,000.
And that's because of the way
that the strings are converted.
When the initialization
takes place,
it essentially converts
price into a dynamic list.
So strong mode
enforces type checking.
And it means you can never
get into such a state
where an expression evaluates
to a value that doesn't match
the expression's static type.
So with strong mode we
get better error messages
earlier so issues like this
are caught immediately.
And so you see here,
this is DartPad
with strong mode turned on.
And you immediately
see that there's
a squiggly line
underneath warning you
that there's an error.
So strong mode, we
think, is a good step
forward for Dart as a language.
It will help with these
broader, big, production-quality
applications.
Secondly, new language features.
I mentioned that we're
evolving and rebooting Dart
to be optimized for the client.
And here's a great example
of how we can reduce
the amount of boilerplates.
So this is a bit of Flutter
code to build a widget.
And, as you may know,
Flutter uses Dart to actually
create and instantiate the UI.
And this is an
interesting challenge.
A lot of languages
try and create
a separate markup language
for the UI declaration
because the language itself is
not really designed around UI.
And with Dart, we think we're
onto something here where
the UI can be expressed
in the same code file
as the rest of your logic,
the model, the view controller
all appearing in the same place.
The problem with
this is that there's
a little too much language
ceremony associated
with the declarations here.
And it gets in the
way of that UI.
In particular, there's
a lot of new and const
to the boilerplate.
You can't miss it out.
And it can actually
cause confusion
if you suddenly forget
to put in a const
and suddenly all the
extra, intelligent help
from the editor
sort of disappears.
So wouldn't it be great if
we could get rid of that
and just focus on
building the UI?
So with this specific
new language feature,
we've made new and
const optional.
And so now you can write
something like this in Dart 2,
where there's not actually
a single Dart keyword
involved in the
declaration of your widget.
Pretty cool, huh?
And following this,
we are looking
at how we can make the
UI-as-code experience even
better with future releases
and iterations of the Dart
language.
And Leaf is going to be
talking a little bit more
about language features
after this keynote.
So you'll hear some
other examples.
The third thing in Dart
2 is the introduction
of a common front-end.
Now, lots of tools
and compilers are
out there already that allow
us to handle Dart code.
Today, most of them are
built independently,
which basically allows
different teams to work fast
and to iterate quickly.
But many of the tasks that
each of these different items
needs to perform
are actually common.
And so that means
there's lots of rework,
lots of these tools
doing the same things.
And worst, there's a
risk of inconsistency
if there are subtle
differences in how
they handle the Dart language.
So with Dart 2,
we're introducing
a new common front-end
to our tooling.
And this front-end, of course,
analyzes the source code
to build an internal
representation of the program.
It manages the symbol tables
and those kinds of things.
And the benefit of that is
that we get more consistency
across these individual pieces.
It means we can move
faster with the language
by adding new features.
And in some cases,
those changes don't even
require back-end changes.
Also, it enables
us, it positions us
well for the future
to make improvements
to the client side
that might actually
take advantage of this.
For example, a new
tool like the one
we introduced last week that
lets you inspect widgets.
So to recap, strong mode,
new language features,
a common front-end.
We just, in this last week,
flipped the Dart 2 switch
for Flutter.
And we're now working
on the remaining issues
to get ready to swap
in the new front-end.
So we'll have full strong mode
and the new language features
available.
OK, so that's Dart.
Let's move up the
stack a little.
And I want to talk
now about Flutter.
Dart has built some
amazing things.
And, really, it's Flutter,
in many ways, that
was one of the first to
actually find the Dart language
and realize its vision and
to build on the innovations
that Dart introduces.
So in some ways, while Dart
is like the high performance
gasoline that powers
the car, Flutter
is the engine that helps
take it forward at speed.
And here is the problem we're
trying to solve with Flutter.
A lot of people are trying to
build mobile apps right now.
And with multiple
popular platforms
for building mobile apps,
historically, there's
been two different
approaches to solving this.
On the one hand,
many people choose
to build for a single
platform at once.
They'll have a team that's
dedicated to building
an iOS application or
an Android application.
And that has many benefits.
Of course, you can
build something
that is really native to
the underlying platform.
But there's also a downside.
You have to have two
separate codebases.
Sometimes teams [INAUDIBLE] have
literally two separate teams
that struggle to connect
together and talk together
and share designs, et cetera.
The alternative approach
that a lot of companies use
is to look at various
cross-platform frameworks that
are becoming increasingly
popular as a way
to use one codebase to target
both platforms at once.
On the plus side, that
means one codebase.
So you can execute
and iterate quickly.
The problem is that
they often trade
performance or native experience
for that single codebase.
For example, they might
be built with JavaScript
as their language and
interpreted at runtime.
Or they just don't
feel native because
of the lowest common denominator
approach to the widgets.
And that's where
Flutter comes in.
Flutter makes it easy
and fast to build
beautiful, native, mobile apps.
Flutter is the best
of both worlds.
It's fast and it's native.
You have a single
codebase, and yet you
can still take full advantage
of the underlying operating
system.
And Flutter is powered by some
great code and engineering
that we've taken
from other places.
The Skia graphics stack,
a fast and powerful
text-rendering engine, and,
of course, the Dart language.
Flutter is a reactive framework.
It has a deep notion of states
that flows through the system.
So it's always clear
what needs updating.
And we only need to repaint
the widgets that need it.
And it being native
means that you can access
always the underlying APIs.
You can still write parts of
your app in Kotlin or Java
or Swift or
ObjectiveC or leverage
other's work with packages
to make that happen as well.
I love this little quote here
that is from "Hacker News."
It feels like the
kind of thing that I
would have written myself, "it
feels like a futuristic version
of the Android SDK."
But rather than me sort of just
share somebody else's quote,
I'd like to invite on to stage
Jere and Tero from Hookle
who are one company who've
built a Flutter app that
is launching today in beta
for Android and for iOS.
Hey guys, are you doing?
TERO SEPPALA: Fine.
Hi, Tim.
Thanks.
JERE SEPPALA: Hi, Tim.
TIM SNEATH: Good to see you.
JERE SEPPALA: Nice to be here.
TIM SNEATH: So tell
me a little bit,
firstly, tell me what is Hookle.
TERO SEPPALA: Well,
Hookle is a young startup
and we have been less
than five months before,
less than five months in here.
TIM SNEATH: Uh-huh.
TERO SEPPALA: Yeah.
TIM SNEATH: OK.
TERO SEPPALA: And we're
developing a social media
management tool on the go.
So we need an application
and tool for developing that.
TIM SNEATH: OK, and so Hookle
is a social media app, right?
TERO SEPPALA: Yes.
TIM SNEATH: Just tell
me a little bit more
about what it does.
TERO SEPPALA: OK.
JERE SEPPALA: Yeah,
you can actually
post to all of your social media
just with one app, one click.
TIM SNEATH: OK.
OK, so why did you pick
Flutter, specifically,
as your technology
to build Hookle.
TERO SEPPALA: Well, that's
a good question and actually
a funny story.
When we started the
company five months ago,
we hadn't heard about
Flutter back then.
So we started to evaluate
these more traditional,
like native Android and
[? React ?] Native kind
of frameworks.
We had our requirements,
like we wanted
to have native-like performance,
smooth user experience.
And we wanted it to run
on both iOS and Android,
not to mention cost efficiently
to develop this all.
And last but not
least, we wanted
it to be out
quickly in timetable
[INAUDIBLE], of course.
TIM SNEATH: OK.
TERO SEPPALA: So
then, these frameworks
didn't fulfill our requirements.
So our developer actually
suggested suddenly Flutter.
And he told us that
it's going to fulfill
all the requirements.
And we were amazed.
And that's actually
why we're here now.
Because we chose Flutter.
And we have our beta version
out on iOS and Android.
TIM SNEATH: Fantastic.
So just tell me a little about
your experiences using Flutter,
then.
Tell me from a
technical level, what
is it about Flutter
that attracts you?
JERE SEPPALA: Tim, out of
all of the good features
Flutter provides, I actually
went to our developers,
thanked them, I
asked them, if you
need to name two most
important features that you
love about Flutter.
So here you go.
Number one, hot reload.
Hot, stateful reload is killer.
And then another one
is the customizable UI.
It's amazing.
You can just customize
anything you want.
That's about it.
TIM SNEATH: Fantastic.
Cool.
So thank you.
So the application is live right
now in beta on both stores,
right?
Tell me a little bit about that.
How can people get it?
JERE SEPPALA: Yeah, well, it's
public beta on Google Play.
So you can get it today.
Just Hookle it.
TIM SNEATH: Hookle
it, there we are.
JERE SEPPALA: A new
word, Hookle it.
And then if you want to use
Apple version, iOS version,
we have a stand-booth there
outside in the break time.
So you can go there
and just give email
and we give it to
you on TestFlight.
TIM SNEATH: Great.
I've seen your app.
It looks beautiful.
It's a really good example of
the power of Flutter in action.
There's a little video of
it behind the scenes there.
But, yeah, I'd encourage
everybody, go download it,
check it out.
And if you want the iOS version
and you're not physically here,
I guess you can email
these guys and they'll
give you a TestFlight code
to activate it, right?
JERE SEPPALA: Yes,
just come to us.
All right.
TIM SNEATH: Cool, hey
guys, thank you so much.
TERO SEPPALA: Thank you.
TIM SNEATH: Thank you
for coming on stage.
JERE SEPPALA: Thank
you, Tim, yes.
[APPLAUSE]
TIM SNEATH: So Flutter
is only in alpha,
but we already have over 200
apps in the Google Play Store.
And we're continuing to see
apps start to take off here.
And we think this is the point
in time where maybe Flutter is
starting to be that firework
that's caught the spark
and maybe starting to
take off a little bit.
We launched Flutter back in--
we announced Flutter,
I should say, at I/O.
And since I/O last
year-- so that's what,
nine months or so--
there's been a whole bunch
of new features added to it,
including things like
right-to-left layout supports,
accessibility, custom UI,
background execution--
you can read the list here--
as well as integrating Dart 2
and the richness of the Dart
language into Flutter.
We're getting very
close to beta.
We're expecting a beta to
be available before I/O. We
have the channel ready.
We're starting to kind of
put the pieces in place.
So whilst we're not announcing
the beta this morning,
stay real tuned because we
are getting very, very close
to the point where
we think Flutter
is ready for prime time.
And a few examples
of some of the things
that we're working on.
As with Dart, everything
in Flutter is open-source,
everything is out
there on GitHub.
So you can go and
see what's going on.
This is a sampling
of some of the areas
where we've been putting
some energy right now
to add new capabilities
including widgets like maps,
and webview, and charts.
We're doing continued
work on accessibility.
We already have
accessibility support,
but that's the journey
we're continuing to work on.
We're adding increased
support for performance,
for text rendering.
We're adding new language
and tooling features
like embedding Flutter
widgets into an existing app
and profiling.
So check it out.
There's the website
there where you can see
everything that's on our radar.
We also love receiving your pull
requests, your contributions,
your issues so we can continue
to make sure that we build
with Flutter a framework
and an SDK that is perfectly
suited for the needs that you
have as a client-app developer.
So the third
stanza, if you like.
We've talked about Dart 2,
the rebooted, client-optimized
language.
We've talked about
Flutter as an example
of one of the rich,
powerful frameworks that
build on the Dart language.
And lastly, I want
to talk a little bit
about some of the tooling that
we have for Dart and Flutter
together.
Firstly, we build great
IntelliJ plug-in support
for the entire stack here.
And that's available for
IntelliJ, for WebStorm,
for Android Studio.
And just this last year, we
shipped 13 different versions
of this.
So we're moving very
fast on the tooling.
You can see a lot
of momentum there.
And you can expect to see
continued delivery of updates
to that.
Our Portland team delivered
a lot of that work.
So thank you to you guys.
We also have a redesigned
package repository
for getting at various
different things
that you need, whether
you're building for the web,
whether you're building
a Flutter mobile app,
or whether you're just
building something that needs
some core Dart functionality.
And relatively uniquely
as a packaging site,
our repo here provides
really good support
for things like reputation.
So when you pick a
particular package here,
we assign it a reputation score
based off number of downloads,
based off a few other metrics.
So it's easier to kind
of see the packages
that you might be
interested in that
are relevant to your needs.
Already we have
over 1,500 packages
at pub.dartlang.org, which
is pretty incredible,
again, given where we're at in
this early stage of our journey
with Dart and Flutter.
And you can see more
packages every day.
There's one that came
out just this last 24
hours from AppTree, who have
built a great maps plug-in.
And so you can see a
bunch of different things
that are coming out here.
One great example of how
the community, how you guys
are all helping us build
a better Dart ecosystem is
this one here, Danny Tuppeny.
Danny, are you here somewhere?
Wave your hand if you're here.
There he is hiding at the
back there because he's shy.
Danny--
[APPLAUSE]
Danny has built this amazing
extension for Flutter and Dart
for Visual Studio Code, which
is a really popular developer
tool.
And again, we're seeing a
lot of interest in this.
It's a great way to build
Flutter or Dart applications.
And I'm pleased
to announce today
that we're bringing Danny
on to work full time with us
for the next 12 months on
continuing to improve this code
extension to make it a really
great alternative to Android
Studio IntelliJ for
building these applications.
[APPLAUSE]
So this is the opportunity
we have right now
between these three
different pieces--
with Dart, this battle-tested,
high-performance, scalable
language; with Flutter,
this beautiful SDK
for building incredible
experiences; with tooling that
supports this; and packages
that the community provides.
We think we're poised for
a really interesting 2018.
We think we've got something
here that is rather unique.
And I'm really excited
by the opportunity
as we move ahead with
this combination.
And others are starting
to see it as well.
For example, this "Medium"
article from Nick Manning
was a really good
article talking
about why he thinks Flutter
will take off in 2018.
Even "Visual Studio
Magazine," who
are maybe not our
most loyal fans,
wrote this article about
how even things like Xamarin
are starting to be
challenged by Flutter.
So the opportunity is here.
You guys are the early adopters.
You were here first.
You've been following
this journey for awhile.
And we think this is the time.
This is the year where Flutter
is going to be amazing.
So I want to close
with a thank you.
Some of you have
done amazing work
to help support us and
get us to this point.
In particular, Alexandre
has 156 pull requests
committed in the codebase
for Flutter and Dart.
And Gunter has been amazing
at answering questions
on stack overflow with
over 2,400 answers
to different questions.
Plus, of course,
we have this stack
of Google developer
experts, most of whom
are here in LA for
the conference.
So I'd like to
particularly thank
you guys for making
this environment great.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
So lastly, what next?
Here at DartConf, we're going
to have a really good time.
We've got, I can't remember
how many sessions, 12, 13, 14,
15 sessions.
We've got an unconference.
We've got lightning talks.
It's a great
opportunity not just
to listen and learn,
but also to network
with other Google engineers,
to network with each other.
Secondly, we want your feedback.
Tell us how we're doing.
Tell us what we need
to continue to invest
and improve on to make this
a great platform for you.
Thirdly, we'd really
appreciate your help.
We are still in
alpha with Flutter.
Dart is still
starting to take off.
We'd really love your support
in being our evangelists,
to spread the good news
of Dart and Flutter.
So if you feel able,
we'd really appreciate
you tweeting or sharing with
your networks a little bit
about your own experiences
with the platform.
And lastly, please contribute.
We have everything
out in the open.
We really do relish
your contributions,
whether it's finding
new bug reports
or whether it's filing issues
or contributing actually
to the code with patches or
widgets or things like that.
So with that, I
want to thank you.
I hope you have a really
good Dart Conference.
Thank you so much for coming.
Have a great day and
today and tomorrow.
Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]